[Music]
what's going on reject nation it's the
day after filming the one division
episode
seven reaction so you know what that
means it's time to check out senpai eric
from new rockstars
see all his easter eggs and break down
and everything that we got wrong
so he can correct us on it it was a
cicada
did nexus mean the nexus being portal
the multiverse stuff or didn't mean the
age of ultron reference what was it
let's check this out and by the way i
see you eric you're wearing the vision
shirt that i ordered too
a few weeks ago i want my favorite this
time next week
should be wearing that shirt hopefully
hopefully if it arrives i just wanted to
arrive at least before the finale
take it to me right now welcome back to
new rockstars i'm eric boss and this is
a breakdown of one division episode
seven
which spoiler warning confirms agnes as
the witch agatha harkness in a basement
dungeon that i wish this blue dungeon
was give me a baphomet yak head any day
of the week and i'll yack your ear off
about it but there is so much
[Laughter]
let's get started okay you may have
noticed how each episode the way wanda
says previously on one division gets
progressively less and less cheerful
i knew we should have listened to the
recap obviously on one division
previously on one division i thought it
was insane
previously on one division previously on
one
[Music]
as division fourth wall illusion
collapses around her the jig is up folks
the fourth wall is broken and now agatha
takes control
i gotta say it's so cool to have a
series
where there's even a little little hints
and a story being told
within the recaps themselves now we have
to make sure
we are not solely talking over it and
trying to do evan peter's impression
because in phase five they're actually
gonna start throwing us off in the ring
reframing this hex as her own show
agatha all along
wanda's cover has a pattern
so is vision scout case but i'm thinking
that
hexagonal maybe reflecting that she is
not really part of this hex but
in her shame she chooses to blanket
herself in the hecks to
try to escape her reality the boys
trollers and then two atari joysticks
and then uno
played by a young monica rambo with her
scroll friend
in captain marvel a relationship i
believe we might be revisiting
now listen to the radio as wanda makes
cereal
your little ghosts arrived
[Music]
okay radio station w
wow how'd you hear that how did you
handle that little ghosts maybe another
clue pointing to the theory i pitched
last week that the children who just
showed up in west view could be the
souls of
dead children maybe the children who
have killed over the years
or one of those kids could be reflected
on this milk carton as a glitch it's now
showing a
missing child photo now this is after
the milk just worked from almond milk to
vitamin d
milk in other words something vegan to
the milk with the most fat in it
i'm not saying they're eating babies oh
yeah i kind of am because
clearly this hex is for the children who
consume their life horse
i did bite a kid once now once cereal
has a smoking [ __ ]
with a clown on it and a circus tint
maze on the back
which is just like the circus themed
trying to get away from this circus back
to the heart of west view
clever three modern sitcoms the piano
music based on the office
see it wasn't only the office it's just
one thing yeah
the office was one thing the rapidly
shifting titles based on the happy
endings intro happy endings was
people were freaking out about
[Music]
in all these home confession camps
handheld ah
that's cool modern family cinematography
as well well then these flashy talks oh
russo brothers got a shout out
number is 12 28 22 a nod to the birth
date of the late great stan lee
dude that's awesome yeah
as in wanda being synonymous for the
word closed
the way she has closed herself off from
the outside world
and there's nothing that's brilliant
dude there's so many little easter eggs
in here that's
brilliant everyone's under her spell
oh yeah that's true way to add i'm
adding to eric
the russo brothers get a little shout
out there with their happy endings
produced
i saw happy endings trending and now i
get wide out but also to get the stan
lee shadow because he probably couldn't
do a cameo
oh that's so clever i love that sorry
we're
wanda that's brilliant that is brilliant
i think it does probably tie in more to
the clothes because so much of this is
about repression
yeah and not dealing with her stuff and
uh not letting people in
yeah it makes sense
there's another one and straight up
kidnapper letters i know what you are
doing the river
i like the idea this could be coming
from agatha shaming wanda into closing
herself
off leaving her kids vulnerable for nom
nom nom now another title shows us some
fridge magnets with b
and s visible in frame as in this west
view sitcom is
[ __ ] and then from hayward's new
sword camp the hex has
expanded so you can see its top edges
are also angled not unlike folks
a circus tent like the circus support
agency
prism like every angle you look at it
there's a hexagon
which shouldn't be possible like think
about how do you link a bunch of planner
hexagons in a way that they all fit
neatly together so this is a theoretical
shape
like a tesseract which in physics is
actually a
fourth dimensional hypercube that's
really only capable of being
cubed as a 3d cube as this fourth
dimensional prism
passes through our 3d dimension i bring
all this up
a similarly trans-dimensional phenomenon
a hex from a dimension beyond our
perception that passes through
our 3d dimension and then warps the
nature of the system within it
and i lost you look if you didn't want
to get creeped out check out this agent
when hayward plants do will probably
nuke a new jersey town
yeah i feel very lucky what's happening
with the broadcast
what the heck is that movement it kind
of looks reversed
or scroll versed now over in the circus
egypt monty
is now the strong man darcy's an escape
artist i know some of the employees
it could have just been a reaction shot
you know everything is a clue
the actor trying to give a little bit
more depth to uh her performance
she doesn't have much to do in this
episode she likes that
what am i thinking and feeling i'm just
saying you know the most exactly it's
like
a little depth you know some of the
employees wear jumpsuits with a circusy
version of the sword crest
later there's a booth for full the
guesser which i feel
this kind of reminded me of arrested
weather shows sunny weather with a
chance of clouds
later when darcy drives she comments how
it never rains in west view yet it does
on them
and this is right after the nexus
commercial in which dark rain clouds
form
billy asks about uncle p and wanda says
don't believe anything that man said
he is not your uncle he's my pistol
pietro and he knows how wanda
threateningly points the remote at these
boys
they look shaken as if mommy might
change them the way their game
controllers were just warped and then
agnes arrives
which is the color of agatha harkness we
actually see agatha harkness's ornate
purple dress in boots for a brief second
at the end of the episode but she has
been rocking agatha's brooch the whole
time the whole time
and we've seen all the clues agnes is an
amalgamation of
agatha hardiness i gotta say eric just
must feel
so good must be vindicated yet do you
remember
last week when i pointed out that
twitter like it's the fifth i mean he
was talking about mephisto specifically
but you know
there was a lot going around that maybe
this is all just nods it's not actually
going to happen but i bet it's like
yes thank god they mocked me in the show
itself
i was right pretty much every word of
her mouth has been suspect the devil's
in the details pav
that's not the only place he is so
agatha of course is the witch who often
accompanies wanda in the comics now
she's not always
evil most of the time she's not actually
kind of a good guy but in the west coast
avengers run that one division seems
partly based on agatha gaslights wanda
into
thinking she has kids who are actually
pieces of methisto's soul as pietro
called them last episode
unleash hell demon spawn demon spawn
now here agnes says i think i got there
in the nick of time
because she was one split end away from
cutting her own bangs
nick of time and her rabbit is in your
scratchy which some think could be
enough you gotta get a son
nicholas scratch and cutting her own
bangs
agnes might have been afraid wanda is
about to cut aka
erase her bangs these things she got by
you know
that i just can't see the mole thing i
heard this is a witchcraft thing related
to this
i get it say no somewhere in common
boxes are associated with witches people
thought it was a mark of the devil but
notice how the camera cuts away wait did
they
really i mean winches always have like a
nosebleed
weirded out by agnes doing this they are
disgusted by whatever it is they see
i'm assuming there's some hideous
pestering mole under there and wanda
says
i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine
i'm fine
stop it stop it
both of them channeling that scene and
get out
it's kind of me when joker says we live
in a society
and by the way if you want to support my
insanity you can check out all of our
great merch options on your
merch.com this is our latest obsession
shirt
how nice it would be to be wearing that
maria hammond got her shirt she just
tweeted at me oh
dude where's my certainty rockstars eric
scowa maria's got one they're they're
playing favorites
yeah new rock stars is playing favorites
with eric boss right now
is unbelievable she'll be the last one
with the shirt okay so jimmy receives
darcy's cataract email and if you look
at his screen darcy ends this email with
this is a decoy communique he sent to
vision's office so that answers who
sent vision that email in episode 5. it
was a ploy
could retrieve his sentient weapon
monica meets up with this sword unit led
by major funny
all right let's see if he thinks this is
a squirrel this might be the squirrel
girl
so is goodner the big mystery engineer
the past two episodes were
setting up to be like a big deal that
everyone thought was gonna be reid
richards well let's think about this
goodner likely worked for
sword space program i'm actually
assuming these are the astronauts who
didn't report back to hayward but
instead of them just not having the
nerve maybe they just thought he was a
dick
undoing maria rambo's legacy and i have
a suspicion that this unit
is a sword division of scrolls maybe the
unit fury is attached to on that space
station let's see if that comes true be
a grown-up version of taylor's daughter
that would be cool that would be clear
because unlike maria and monica he views
aliens as
threats and they're not yet revealing
themselves to jimmy wu because
he brainstormed scrolls as possible
perpetrators of all this but they could
totally trust him just look at it he's a
racist
dammit coffee he's the best now the tag
number 9219r
are probably for rover 9219 could be a
nod to the year 1992
which would have been in the window of
time soren her daughter and the other
squirrels were hidden
hey i mean if they are squirrels that's
cool that's a cool knot
it happened in 1992 maybe 1992 was the
first year they built this river darcy
tells vision
fine i'll go out with you but i'm
ordering the lobster now remember
lobster was on the menu back in the
first episode
so i like this little thing of darcy
being kind of a stan hey there's fake
lays in the background
could be a nod of the one in agents of
shield remember skye had one of these
in those framework episodes that was the
event where olson ranted about the hydra
soap that we've talked about before
as the house glitches the historic
returns and then one says this to the
confession
cam i can't fix it do you think
maybe this is what you deserve what
you're not supposed to do
it sounds like agatha's voice this
reminded me of like the moment
pitch down pitch down member appears on
screen for the first time and everyone's
like
what the [ __ ] they're actually
committing to this format that dude from
entourage
which kind of made it silicon valley
silicon valley
looking up in weird role-playing
scenarios now this is my favorite detail
episode later the agave all along
sequence revealed agatha to be the one
behind the camera agatha probably the
director of this show
but this male voice here is actually
katherine han's voice
ah we got it we got it hell yeah we
didn't say that in the reaction
you think maybe this is what you deserve
next this commercial force
nexus anti-depressant and holy [ __ ] my
theory was right
roll that clip john do not be surprised
if this next commercial
in the modern family era is a
stereotypical pharmaceutical ad
medication for anxiety depression folks
this doesn't always happen
and mephisto ain't in this show this
might be the only vindication i get
anyway the reality of your choice the
world revolving around you yeah these
are all references to wanda maximoff
being a nexus
being in marvel okay oh we got it this
is separate from
any one reality or timeline because this
is how one that was able to flip
it feels good when we get something
right because there's always so many
comments they're like we're all right
about this there's like
five other contexts for that yeah
because we were like oh the nexus
it might mean age of ultron uh
but i was like well maybe an age of
ultron the they named it nexus
in reference like that was the reference
yeah uh
to the nexus beings and all that because
of all reality
because wanda was being introduced in
there and all that here i was like no
it's probably a direct
connection this time as opposed to a
reference yeah
yeah anyway the multiverse just wanted
to pause the video to be like oh my god
there's something we
hear her eric's getting vindicated we
are getting vindicated this is a good
this is a vindicative reaction yes
catharsis well he's in house of m and
this tells us that this series
is probably setting up the marvel
multiplayer yeah exactly you can see
this bottle behind ismar there reads
multi
probably from multivitamin but the word
multi's there so this is a big deal
even if evan peters pietro is not
quicksilver from the fox
x-men universe clearly with this hex
expanding and expanding
that could be one way reality is
rewritten in a house of m way to create
the multiverse a crisis that they'll
have to deal with in loki and spider-man
3 and multiverse madness bear in mind
characters like jean grey and kang the
conqueror are also technically nexus
beans so i think we'll get a much
clearer definition of what exactly this
means with the tva and loki
i love how we're always talking about
multiverse problems
always with spider-man 3 and multiverse
and madness yes
but we never bring up ammunition i'm
like
guys it's probably going to play in some
way
why is everyone not taught they say
nexus beings and king the conquerors the
nexus being come on
ant-man three throw them in the
conversation i'm sure
it's gonna it's gonna count look at that
word nixopromicide
that suffoxide means something that
kills
like spermicide so this is 10.3 nexus
promoting
killing as in wanda is using her nexus
status to reset reality
to kill off 10.3 percent of people
no more mutants or you could read this
as an active ingredient that kills
off or reduces by 10.3 percent
one's affinity to use the nexus to
chaotically rewrite reality
giving wanda greater control over what
would normally be super chaotic i love
the way this commercial shot this woman
lays
down in bed but then they rebuild the
set so that the bed is
on a wall as she steps away from so her
reality was literally turned on its axis
so that she can actively step forward
from that depression sinkhole on
a level plane in the corner of the
screen you know what i'm starting to
wonder
is if these people are her uh
who are our parents the two actors yeah
they're always in these same commercials
yeah yeah oh that's a that's a very
interesting because
because we deal so much with trauma and
granted all the traumas have been like
marvel related things that we've
explored
right yeah i think her we never explored
her parents no and so i'm starting to
wonder if like maybe these are the
people who were her parents
and you know this woman's got a little
bit of that reddish in her hair i mean
she kind of looks like wanda
yeah actually looks like she could be
someone who they hire to play
yeah elizabeth olsen's mom with so much
significance around all of these things
i feel like the casting could very
easily
not be just a useless detail there or
her father was a shark because it's the
same actors every time right in the
corner of the screen it reads
see our ad in the west view gazette and
not in the newspaper that keeps showing
my favorite breakdown in hayward's eyes
and the voiceover also says ask your
doctor
which could be a nod to dr strange being
the doc who helps break wanda's
addiction to this reality warping in
multiverse of madness
and it ends with this woman stepping to
the right into this red glow
as if to say the way forward little lady
is to take this nexus med
become queen of your own reality war
into a red
tinted hex and then billy tells agnes
you're quiet agnes
on the inside a signal that billy as a
telepath death ended by all the noise in
westview is unable to read agatha's
thoughts
or the thoughts of the quiet senor
scratchy actually notice when called out
agatha freezes
her hand just over the rabbits is ready
to
activate him into a new form and agnes
mentions ralph
ralph says i sugarcoat things but you
try telling a 10 year old that his
mother is cuckoo for cocoa puffs
now on the table before her are these
violet flowers with
leafy stems these look like the flowers
that are all over her yard the leaves
look like what billy was just feeding to
the rabbit or it could have been spinach
or it could have been these leaves
my theory is that this plant is the
wounded gore ever bloom
has hair been doing with some backlash
lately eric
is on edge what's up he's been getting
bombarded with questions lately and it's
been challenged on his theories when
quarantine is over i'll i'll give you a
massage
if you like you just to loosen up it's
gonna be okay
it's okay eric wundergore ever bloom the
plant that grows in agatha darkness is
yard in the comics
that once eaten gives one visions of
what life could be via
feelings of pain in the tom king i mean
you just
justified it really well absolutely
and i believe agatha killed sparky for
digging up this plant
in her yard and that she has been
driving with this planet
[Laughter]
dude i mean it sounds great it sounds
great
dinner in episode one her booze in
episode two the lavender spray in
episode five
and now in a medicinal form notice that
wanda
pops pills and what does agnes do for
when she arrives
bruise her teeth i'm assuming some
herbal tea
she even makes an herb out of herb and
why is she doing this well
in the fantasy so that agatha didn't
consume the life force of her children
now did agnes actually gobble up these
kids like the witch and the hansel and
gretel story no no they're probably
locked up somewhere
or part of some kind of ritual somewhere
deep in that dungeon as they are being
what reassumed in mephisto maybe drained
of their energy but
like house of them i think this is all
gonna end with wanda not being able to
hold on to these kids
now monica activates a spectrometer
and monica pushes herself through
break down all the lines that were the
subtitles on disney plus
break them down eric this audio is from
the captain marvel film we actually
heard
this softly as monica unblipped back in
episode four now captain marvel this is
the scene where carol and maria and fury
were about to launch i can't leave
monica mom
it's okay i gotta stay with grandma and
paw paw there's no way i'm going baby
it's too dangerous
maybe i could fly up and meet you
halfway oh only if you learn to glow
like your auntie carol but i
love the visuals of this monica's face
stretches from
itself like in the movie contact when
jodie foster has an interview
and her face is here but it's also
better
this visual inspired doctor strange's
trip through the multiverse and i bring
it up because that is essentially what
is happening here
contact changed everything spectrum of
her various roles in her life
she unblitz you got more than i do
think about it this is kind of the order
of her life priorities
as she's progressing forward daughter
first and then starbound explorer and
then
country serving agent and then maximum
selflessness
even in defiance of her own country a
sacrificial empath
just trying to talk an avenger off a
ledge but then monica pulls
all of herselves into one and then
sticks the superhero line
her eyes are now glowing blue and she
sees the westview anomaly in its true
irradiated state kinda like neo see in
the matrix yeah
that's what i dude
thank you we're gonna be weeping at the
end of this video
by sinking all of her past selves all of
her past stumbles and all of her past
arising but uh i gotta say this one
looks
way that's way better match the color
scheme and close a photon in the comics
dennis the man why
[Music]
presto about a rabbit feuding with his
magicians during his show
similar to the way senor scratchy ran
amok during vision's magic show
something ag that just revealed was her
doing so i believe senior scratchy
is either agatha's son nicholas scratch
and that might be who evan peters pietro
is think about it rabbits are quick
little speedsters
the other option is senior scratchy
could be old scratch
agatha's husband ralph but i'm not going
to go as far to say that
is the mailman but the fact that he is
wearing this rabbit logo means that he
is like all these things are under axis
control
i'm wondering what is in those brad
delay packages though maybe some
supplies to help agatha maintain this
drugging
now agnes breaks up the heart belt
moment between monica and wanda
wonder young lady i think you overstayed
you're welcome
run along dear young lady dear it's like
little old lady colloquialisms
hey deary why don't you take the words
i'm missing ncis
now in agnes's home there are hexagon
patterns on the cups
[Music]
listen to them they're saying jump jump
jump
almost as if inviting wanda to take the
plunge into the basement now some say
you can see the chair
move on its own behind wanda as she
turns to look at senor scratchy but this
is really a trick of the eye folks see
the camera
starts in a pan and then curves around
wanda's face right as she turns her head
no you don't no it's professor x rocking
in his chair
he's rolling in it's just scooting
itself behind the wall but it's just the
way the camera is pointed but then
wanda sees this you know other people
reach out to you said you symbolize
immortality these things sleep for like
17
years before they hatch there could be a
parallel here with agave
who might stay dormant for years and
years and then re-emerge to make her
move
personally i can't help but see this as
a nod to the silence of the lambs the
moment chloe starling sees the moth in
the home of buffalo bill and that's how
she realizes she is out
and then goes down to the basement she's
hiding horrors in the basement
and down there wanda finds she should
have just been flying in my head's
desire
now first notice how the aspect ratio
widens telling us that wanda has
left the hex temporarily this dungeon is
in the real world now in this place
folks an
animal head across the way this is
either a goat a
ram i'm thinking maybe a yak something
baphomet like
demonic faces are carved into the
pillars above hexagons
with golden symbols etched in you can
see more
animal bones in a red lit cabinet a
winged creature in another corner and of
course the big one
this glowing book most likely the dark
hole
the demon who in the comics cursed wanda
maximoff with her powers as a baby
the darkhold appeared in agents of
shield it had a different cover agent's
shield
unfortunately is not really considered
canon by kevin feige so this is probably
just going to be colson's
in there symbol on it looks like two
keys joining together to open a central
lock
now i've speculated this book could be
from the camera tag library which would
root want a sorcery in dr strange's
eldritch
geometric shape like many of the
sorcerer's spells take these interesting
angular geometric shapes now some are
saying this could be the necronomicon
which was derived from the dark hold i
think it's more likely to just be the
darkhold and it's going to be used to
justify all the supernatural elements in
the mcu
like blade but here this is likely this
is
this witch is putting over wanda because
of that this is
a satanic temple and the witch who
occupies it reveals herself the name's
agatha
lovely to finally meet you dear and then
an amazing revised intro sequence
revealing it was
agatha all along notice how agatha
starts by floating to the ground to help
this domestic family
like mary poppins who is a witch don't
forget that and then the lyrics say she
pulled
every evil string but it's interesting
it doesn't say anything about her
creating this x it just makes her sound
like she's meddling in the hex
but all this includes senior scratchy
herb
pietro killing sparky she lied to vision
and it looks like it was to get him to
leave and get him out of the picture so
that
she and pietro could move in on those
kids this whole sequence the music
sounds like it's a monster's theme but
notice the female vocals here actually
done by catherine honors that's so cool
i love that
oh yeah i learned that this morning
oh that's awesome think of a picnic as
pietro arrived
perhaps that creepy appendage we saw in
the mirror was her magic pulling him
into the house
now pietro also i would love for that
arm thing to be justified
surprising monica when she snoops into
the basement snooper's going to snoop
oh you'll notice monica's eyes but i
don't think this means agatha's magic
has hold of her
because she still reacts cognitively to
pietro she's not in a trance yet i just
think as
photon her eyes illuminate to reveal
energy that wouldn't normally be visible
to the naked eye like how they glowed
blue
earlier but interesting here notice
agnes's car has a connecticut license
plate not a new jersey one
agnes did mention how her and ralph's
anniversary was june 2nd the day the
salem witch trials began in 1692.
salem is in massachusetts but at the
time which trials and executions were
happening
all over new england including
connecticut but as monica peaks into the
door look at the window to the right a
shadow moves independent of monica's
reflection this is something else inside
i'm thinking this could be senor
scratchy turned into pietro and
presto darted over to monica to catch
her look folks i'm not going to try to
fool you actually is clearly the villain
of the show westview is her operation
but she's got associations with
witchcraft with dark magic
and there's still a very good chance she
has a silent partner that we haven't met
yet
and all signs are pointing to mephisto
not just the devil in the distance
i want you to win i care more about you
that's the biggest of this show still an
unseen major cameo popping up
there is one character that has not been
revealed
and it is very exciting as an actor that
i've
longed to work with all of my life and
in the same interview paul bettany
seemed
really coy about mephisto in particular
i can't speak to
right now because i'm worried about
getting uh fired so as great as this
reveal is i think most of us did see it
coming so
there is probably one deeper mystery
left in the shadows
the darkest is yet to come hey by the
way
a giveaway all you gotta do is subscribe
to the channel epic hero labs and then
head over to epic heroshop.com
giveaway for more ways to enter you can
continue this nerdy conversation on new
rockstar's official discord server by
becoming a patron at patreon.com for all
your wanted visions thank you for
watching
and uh singing along with me who gets
his theories ten point three percent
right
it was eric boss all along
hey no you gotta give yourself more
credit you're at least at fifteen
percent
oh you're you're way on to it dude i
thought you killed it
game
so much more just because of you yeah
it's mainly because of it
how these breakdowns have grown and they
almost because of the show's lore they
have their own little lore of your
theories coming true and yeah
i'm i'm i'm so heavily rooting for
mephisto just for you i mean the fact
that we got this far
with witchcraft and also with seeing all
the satanic stuff in the room that she's
in
like well looks like they're willing to
bring in a little mephisto disney
take the gamble and see if china down
the road is going to be willing to let
some satanism play into their marvel
theaters
so i guess to be fair like in the lore
it's not
literally hell it's just another
dimension so maybe exactly you can
explain it through that
technically it's justified in some way
yeah i might have to watch some of their
lines
that's why they made that thing about
the ghost children so low on the radio
that
none of us could even hear it and also
you know what this video really helped
point out for me too
is the handling of monica rambo how a
lot of times when you go into
especially i remember like around the
phase two era of things
guys just focus on your movie why are we
setting up this other character why are
we trying to like
jam some type of like little origin into
this this one movie
it can feel like too much and they
should have just stated for a different
film or something like that
and with monica rambo they've been
successfully pulling
off the origins of photon spectrum
in here in a way that doesn't feel like
too much like they're
giving us her origin tale without
shoving it in our face and
making it feel like the show's about her
but it's all unfolding to where
she can do her own thing down the road
yeah like they've made a really nice
thing out of that because there have
been little things in these
easter egg videos even for us to go like
does she ever powers already and
certainly looking at it here it seems
like maybe a little bit but they're
certainly coming into
bigger fruition because of this yes and
i still think though that even if
quicksilver isn't
quicksilver necessarily like if it isn't
evan peters pietro
from the multiverse of the x-men films i
would still say
that what's cool about him being casted
if it is just like some stunt casting
thing
is it goes to show that the x-men movies
they didn't
not matter you know what i mean yeah
like the only reason
the only reason bless you the devil oh
he's gonna come inside of you
you're mephisto the only reason that's
so exciting
is due to the fact that evan peters was
in the x-men films and that's what it's
playing on and then when you're hearing
about the other spider-man movies that
are not
mcu-related like dr octopus green goblin
that's also saying like those
did it not matter either in a way it is
cool that feige along with
the team are going hey maybe we're doing
our own canon and maybe the seven peters
thing was just some fun stunt casting
but that's also to say that we wouldn't
be here today if it wasn't for those
movies
you know so i still think in a way it's
honoring yeah definitely but i i hope it
is kevin peters quicksilver
at the end of the day yeah yes all right
guys well
what did you think about this breakdown
i love the hell out of this yes
this is a super entertaining one leave
your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell check out
more videos from new rock stars like
post daily
subscribe to us as well last but not
least
jan valente jn my dude
you know what i just want to come from a
sincere place today i want to say thank
you
you've been a part of our patreon page
for
like the beginning we started longest
people around
even though like we might not hear from
you for a long time could be months on
end maybe we're not even watching our
stuff
you still stay pledged you are
undoubtedly one of our most
loyal patrons we've ever had one of our
most loyal supporters when i think of
the ensemble of patronagex you're one of
the names
the kind of one directly they're going
to the top man so thank you so much
for sticking through with us and always
believing us and always showing your
support
you're a weird wacky guy but you got a
great heart
absolutely change not a thing love you
buddy thank you